in central Ghana making a living is not
easy many people here process and fry
Gary
it's a storable flour made of greater
than fermented cassava gary is popular
in Ghana and other African countries
Mary yeah well a mother of three is one
of the Gary producers golly don't abuse
the traditional open fire teeth to fry
Gavi for 17 years that's what I was
friend with there were that I was
directly as opposed to smoke from the
fire and I spent so much money on a fire
the traditional open fire pit produces a
lot of smoke
it's estimated that the toxic fumes kill
thousands of people each year
therefore Mary was happy when she
learned about a new kind of stove pin
with the new stores I don't inhale smoke
while frying Gary and I used less
firewood that I make so much more Gary
than before jaha makalah near your movie
atomically
the new stoves are hand made from clay
they have only a small hole on one side
for the firewood this means the heat is
stored would use is very efficient and
there's hardly any smoke the stove costs
over 170 euros and were invented by the
Dutch Development Organisation snv the
ngl also facilitates bank loans for
people to be able to afford to buy them
we try to pitch the mention viability of
financing improved cookstoves to this
bank and and we give them a lot a lot of
reasons to want to see this one benefit
of the improved gary stove is that it
needs just a third of the fuel wood in
Ghana deforestation is a huge problem
the country has lost
of its forests since the early 1990s
making firewood an expensive commodity
earlier meri awaz spent almost 20 euros
enroute to produce one sack of Gary now
it's just 7 euros the benefits have been
enormous now I make enough profits from
my business a competitor care of my
family according to the Dutch
Development Organisation over 115 proved
gary stoves of an installed so far and
with hundreds of thousands of Germans
involved in agriculture a lot more could
follow